this looks a lot like what we were doing
before with the same right it's the
model right angled triangle you've got
some random measurements around and they
want you to find their produce okay
now I'm telling you in advance we're
going to use the cosine roof for this in
a second I'm going to show you how do
you work out what rule you actually use
so the cursor and rule I'm gonna begin
according my move so that I get it right
see I always like to start writing
you'll see different textbooks will
write their eighties and B's and C's in
different water I like writing it in
this order because it helps you remember
that it's just like Pythagoras just like
Pythagoras but there's this little funny
extra bit hanging on the end okay
they're funny extra bit is the trickiest
parts remember so now I'm gonna fit in
all of these pieces to what I know okay
I'm going to make this subject the piece
of information of trying to find that's
X okay then what you've got appearing is
the other two sides square just like in
Pythagoras right 15 squared plus 18
squared it doesn't matter which ones and
which ones be cuz if I switch them
around new thing squared plus 18 squared
is the same as 18 squared plus 15
squared so you can do them any which way
you like which is great then I take away
- lots of I go back to this sides again
and I take their products I multiply
them 15 times 18 and my final piece is
this angle hanging on over here cos 35
degrees so you're gonna reach me
calculator again right because of all
these funny little long exact values and
we're going to touch this out and can we
get a number and maybe get a couple of
decimal places which would be great
a hundred and six have you done the next
step
breakfast I think 3549 yeah and then
have you done this bit I can show all
right I guess so sorry 100 and so I've
got my number down but it's really
important you see why I drew this
intermediate step you could have seen
from your common sense check but that's
a ridiculous lengths 4x X can't possibly
be a hundred and six centimeters because
look at the other lights that you've got
happening here right now what you the
reason why we're getting students number
is because it's not the length it's the
length squared
so my next step is I have to take the
square root of that number and who's got
it for me can we get one decimal place
ten point three ten point three two one
decimal place and sure enough that does
look reasonable it looks like it's in
the right ballpark